the story centers on phil Mickelson's
pretty election for gambling would walk
us through what happened here so these
guys were golf buddies walters and davis
apparently knew each other from living
near a golf course and being a part of
the same club way back when they became
friends Mickelson also was somehow
related to these folks and had certainly
played golf with Walters they also like
to gamble apparently and that was maybe
Mickelson's problem with all of this he
owed some money to Walters at one point
and he also benefited from some of the
tips that came from Davis to Walters and
then some of them went on so to
Mickelson us attorney preet bharara
calling this a brazen scheme what does
he mean by that you know this wasn't a
one-off this isn't one time you know
somebody give me a heads up about
something this was systematic over a
year's earnings call after earnings call
spin off another company's looking to do
an acquisition in each of those cases
they've created a whole little network
here we'll give you a prepaid phone
we'll have some code words for how we
communicate this and we'll execute it in
such a way for big profits Walters is
accused of netting 43 million dollars
Phil Mickelson here a relief defendant
help us out with that terminology here
he has not been charged that's right
insider trading is not named by the
prosecutors at all he is named in an sec
complaint in which he's not being sued
but he's agreeing to pay back the money
he got you know I think of this a little
bit sometimes we'll see a case in which
a family member trades on some
information that was passed but wasn't
part of the scheme it was an inadvertent
action so the money you know was
questionable and how it was earned but
not part of the original scheme so
that's what they're calling a relief
defendant in this case I think Mickelson
is probably very happy to pay this money
and have it all go away with no legal
entanglements going back to that trade
what was it the cause Dean Foods his
stock to spike the next day so it's not
just one there's bunches of them he was
getting early information on earnings
more than once multiple times he also
got early information about a possible
spin-off of the company all of this was
non-public and was being passed by Davis
you hacked remember he's chairman of the
board he certainly knew he had a
fiduciary duty and he was passing that
on to Walters Davis had money troubles
at various points and he was benefiting
which is why this is a very clear-cut
example of insider trading he was
getting money back from Walters for
either loans or for capital or friends
estimates and he too had money issues
Phil Mickelson has he commented he has a
good lawyer he's Barack Obama's former
lawyer Greg Craig from Skadden yeah
what's he saying about all this because
he's vindicated he's innocent he did
nothing wrong yes he may have been
tipped off the head go buy a stock but
he had no reason to believe that that
was insider information or non-public
information therefore he got swept up
and benefited from something but he
certainly wasn't part of any scheme
today we had people are making an
announcement what do we learn about the
criminal case so what's interesting
Davis has pled guilty I mean in addition
to executing all of these tips and
sharing of information he did more than
that he perjured himself when he was
questioned about it he tried to destroy
evidence he took this a burner phone and
he tried to throw it into the water so
it'd be destroyed and not prosecutors
couldn't get to it the information
stacked up against him so badly he's
cooperating he's now pled guilty I don't
know what kind of a agreement might be
reached in terms of his sentence Walters
is fighting this walters's said he did
nothing wrong his lawyer says he'll be
vindicated but that will be the next
wave will be a prosecution against Billy
Walters